hey I'm Dan Morrison I'm a researcher in
the Microsoft AI for Earth program and
we are using computer vision to help
ecologists study wildlife populations
but one of the ways ecologist study
animals is by putting motion-triggered
cameras out in the wild so typically you
might go out and put out a couple
hundred cameras come back a few months
later pull all the SD cards over off of
those cameras and now you have anywhere
from a hundred thousand to five million
images that you have to go through
figure out which ones have animals and
which animals are in all those images
this can take months or even years and
we'd like to use computer vision machine
learning to help ecologist do this
faster so we've built a model and an API
machine learning model and an API that
finds animals in images and identifies
what those animals are to help a call it
just do their work faster let me show
you how that works right now so I'm
gonna go ahead and you know if I'm
really an ecologist I'm working in a
particular region of the world and I
would have a set of species that I want
to recognize so I'm going to go up here
and pick out a classifier and say I am
studying animals today I'm gonna upload
images that came from East Africa so I'd
like you to use your East African
trained classifier then I'm going to
upload a whole bunch of images
now we're on to models on those images
one of them is one that's going to find
but not identify animals crop those
animals out those little crops are gonna
get fed to a second model that's
specific to this ecosystem it's going to
classify what those animals are and
while it's thinking I'll remind everyone
that this web UI is just a demo we
wouldn't actually ask anybody to upload
a million images through their browser
we have a API that we host to run
millions of images at a time for actual
ecology workflows as you see on this
image up here our detector model said
hey that looks like an animal
we crop that animal out and fed it to
our classifier and this was correctly
classified as a giraffe we have this one
that was correctly detected and then
classified as a warthog this one is
really important this was correctly
classified as empty because in fact a
lot of what we're trying to do is help
ecologist get rid of empty images here
we have very subtle an animal that was
correctly detected and classified as a
fox and this one correctly detected and
then classified as a gazelle and so when
you think about multiplying this times
millions of images we think that using
computer vision machine learning can
significantly accelerate ecologist
workflows and help them get back to
planning conservation instead of
clicking on images thanks